physically I'm tired my feet are  starting to bother me and I have low  energy just not eating all day so I want  to find something to eat no I've never  eaten green blueberries I just want to  try and see if they're any good  not very good everything tastes better  when you're hungry but not something I'd  eat if I had a lot of food what I really  need to find is some animal food to eat  I have not eaten anything other than a  few leaves and some green berries and  it's getting late I'm tired I'm ready to  go to bed and this is the place where  possibly there's some fish  I don't know if there's anything in here  I think up here the fishing's probably  not that good there's something  there is one there  [Applause]